when shaquille o'neal invites you to be
a part of his super bowl pre-game show
you go just like offset goes
quavo nelly chad ochocinco
tim tebow winnie harlow the current wwe
champion drew mcintyre terrell owens
diplo olivia culpo the miz
ezekiel elliott and former defensive
tackle of the san francisco 49ers
spice adams who would become my nemesis
it was a star-studded affair so lux and
i
got on our first airplane in an entire
year
which was weird right it's like i forgot
how to fly
but i had an electronically ventilated
mask which prevents my glasses from
fogging up
and uh we had a good time we got to
tampa and it was like the super bowl was
happening or something man i mean the
energy was
there when we checked into the hotel i
was so excited
to unpack this suitcase which i packed
an entire
year ago and never got to use
oh whoa oh [ __ ] i remember you showing
me this this is cool
[ __ ] yeah so oh guess i hang in the
closet
and we were staying in ybor city which
is like new orleans of florida
it's just like walking down bourbon
street when we went out at night i think
i might look like i'm from out of town
me ybor city was still going off at like
three in the morning it's 3 12
in the morning
and then we try to go to sleep and pop
up
i mean gunshots there had to have been
like 30 of them so lux says
grab the camera as she runs out onto the
balcony i'm like my girl's nuts
and he never seen so many cops it was
just pandemonium
we finally fell asleep and then woke up
and went to the shack bowl
which started off with rigorous covent
testing
which thankfully we passed and we are
covered
clear we get into the building and shaq
was one of the first people we saw
hey brother
so they got team kansas city which i was
on and
team tampa bay which spice adams was on
so they're gonna have us compete in all
these goofy challenges which i'm pretty
sure that i'm gonna dominate
and one of my teammates is olivia culpo
and before the competition starts
she comes over to let me know we've got
to win
and i am counting on you for a few
things surfboard challenge i tell you
and she asked me do i have any dance
moves i'm like you know what
i do that's pretty good
that's pretty good i feel confident and
then they introduce us
this guy may be the craziest and the
biggest jackass i've ever met
the one and only steve-o
and here comes the dance-off but i have
no confidence in my dancing
so i throw this front flip onto my back
and i try to spring up
but i failed to get up and i'm just
wiggling around on the floor like a
loser while
diplo's laughing at me and ah it was
awful
and even though i tried my butt off we
totally lost because spice
adams brought it
and then we got absolutely murdered in
tug-of-war
then we learned what it's like to play
dodgeball against a star quarterback
i mean you gotta love how tim tebow is
taking charge of his team
tampa bay then i got a nice little break
from getting my ass kicked when there
were performances by
shaq and jack harlow and then migos
performed which was totally killer man
it was like our own private show
and after the performances i was feeling
really good because next up came the
surfing event
and i'm a surfer plus i was killing it
in practice
before the event i was juggling beach
balls the idea was to throw the beach
balls at the person while they're on the
surfboard
tim tebow gave me a free shot [ __ ] just
wasn't going my way so i just thought
get me on this surfboard
when it was time to compete i blew it
i lasted a total of 22 seconds and then
spice adams went
he's a super cool very nice guy but he
ruined my day
he's stolen every event from me i think
they rigged it though
ezekiel elliott was sure they rigged it
it was red it was right
and for the sit-up competition it was me
and cuevo
versus offset and tim tebow i mean come
on
and quavo is wearing like 30 pounds of
diamonds around his neck
so i asked him how much does it all cost
how much
money is around your neck right now this
is probably a little light ticket
we call it a ticket as a m you dig what
i'm saying the million
we got about 300 right here on the wrist
you know what i'm saying
and we got some custom [ __ ] right here
we got the super bowl ring i already won
i love it but i wasn't gonna take it
laying down no no no no i sat
right on the ground and i gave it hell i
had shaq
pushing me and quavo pulling me and i
still lost i was not thrilled with how
my day was going
so i decided on a morale booster by
filming a trick shot where i kick a
basketball into the hoop
but i'm kicking air balls almost nailing
people in the face
and when it comes to trick shots i am
very professional i treat
every attempt like it is the one
i was at it for a while and then who
comes over to tell me i'm
owen 65. spice atoms
about to lose all your memory then
perhaps for the very first time in my
life i gave up on a trick
shot because i had to the obstacle
course event needed to happen
i thought you couldn't do it i'm so sad
and part of the obstacle course event
was shooting hoops which took me about
tries steve come on i don't know that i
could have done any worse
my team lost where's spice
vice is the mvp over here i was
humiliated
of course i didn't want to let on that i
was humiliated
i jumped into shaq's arms
then after that we had a great time
watching the super bowl
how could he not tom brady is gorgeous
and so
is this mug and for one person who goes
to stevo.com to buy my mug shot mug
i'm going to include my
stevo shack bowl jersey
let me sign this mother right
again if you buy a stevo mug you
automatically enter for a chance
to have this jersey show up in the mail
with
the mug yeah
dude all right so there it is get
yourself a stevo mug
and thanks for watching